on november 27 2011 a comet was spotted
traveling towards earth
this comet's existence was confirmed by
mount john university observatory on
december 1st
of that year and the next day the minor
planet center gave it a name
comet c 2011 w3 scientists continued to
observe this comet's trajectory
which appeared to be nothing out of the
ordinary that is until c
2011 w3 reached perihelion c 2011 w3
like many objects entering
the solar system had been pulled into
orbit around the sun
and perihelion is a scientific term
which refers to the point at which an
object in orbit
is the closest to the star it's orbiting
on december 13th
as c-2011w3 approached perihelion
solar dynamics observatory observed a
fragment splitting off from the main
body of the comet
a fragment that then began hurtling
towards earth
despite the scp foundation's
implementation of deterrence procedures
the comet stayed its course and soon it
became clear that areas near the
predicted crash site would have to be
evacuated
on december 21st the comet reached the
earth
crashing into the pacific ocean 124
kilometers off the coast of the united
states
this in itself wasn't unusual on average
our planet is hit by 17 pieces of space
debris a day
and much of it does land in the ocean
what was unusual however
was that three days later the creature
that had been riding the piece of space
debris
reached land and revealed itself to the
world
starting on december 24th 2011 footage
started cropping up
all over the internet of an otherworldly
creature it appeared to be an enormous
deer
with mint green fur a long neck human
face
and marbled black antlers ringed by
floating ice crystals and metallic
spheres
the scp foundation quickly mobilized in
order to contain the beast
but it was immediately evident that it
was impervious to attacks
what was worse it had a devastating way
of retaliating against
aggressors fitting its cosmic origins
the deer possesses the godlike ability
to instantly transmute
matter through powerful energy beams it
can turn
solids into liquids gases into solids
and organic matter into metal
instantaneously
the materials that result from these
transmutations remain stable
despite outside factors that logically
should destabilize them
for example the deer can create shapes
made of solid frozen hydrogen that
remains solid
even outside of the sub-zero
temperatures that it normally requires
to keep gases in their solid states
this transmutation ability is used
consciously as a form of attack
and the beams occur in a variety of
shapes around the creature
the most common are a vertical column
measuring five to seven meters in
diameter
and sixty to eighty meters in height or
a horizontal cone
measuring between 100 and 150 meters in
length
and 10 to 30 meters in width at the
furthest end
although the deer rarely attacks without
provocation it will transmute matter
indiscriminately
making no effort to exclude
non-combatants from the range of the
attack
everything within the range of attack is
transmuted
people hit with the beam will be
transformed into hexagonal columns
roughly 2.4 meters in height
known as scp-2845-1
these columns have rubbery green skin
and no organs outside of a brain
which makes up the entirety of the
columns inside miraculously they remain
alive
as the brains of instances of scp-2845-1
have been studied and are shown to be in
a constant state of high activity
analysis of brainwave patterns suggest a
pattern of call and response
which implies a telepathic link between
the different instances of scp-2845-1
given the devastating effects of
scp-2845's attacks
the scp foundation naturally had an
extremely difficult time containing it
and they had to take drastic measures to
do so the foundation enlisted the help
of the global occult coalition
as well as outside consultants who were
brought in to try and draft a plan for
containment of the beast
the ideal place for its containment was
determined to be somewhere on the other
side of the sierra nevada
mountains and through a campaign of
artillery bombardment that lasted from
december
26 2011 to january 15 2012
the scp and goc were able to drive
scp-2845 across the mountains to
the location that would become known as
site 100.
what sets site 100 apart from other scp
containment sites
is the complex system put in place in
order to properly keep
scp-2845 in containment the
site consists of nine concentric
circular bands
designated ring a through ring i with a
gap located between ring c
and ring d six circular chambers are
located at 0
60 120 180 240 and 300 degrees within
each ring and gap
the chambers located at zero degrees are
aligned with geographic north
two additional circular chambers are
located outside of ring eye
located at 120 and 240 degrees the floor
of each circular chamber is decorated
with a hexagram
or six-pointed star made of lead the
central chamber
containing scp-2845 and 216
instances of scp-2845-1
is to contain an atmosphere of 96.3
hydrogen 3.25 helium and 0.45
ammonia maintained at negative 110
degrees centigrade
site 100 must be staffed at all times by
a minimum of 30 trained individuals
or to be given unlimited access to
untrained human subjects
the staff and subjects must perform a
complex series of rituals at different
points of the circle
acting on a cycle of 63 hours and 54
minutes
each ritual lasts 39 minutes and they
must be performed
every 10 hours at the beginning of each
new cycle
the schedule of rituals will be carried
out in the next ring closest to the
containment chamber
going from ring eye inwards until they
reach ring
a each ritual requires six participants
procedure 410 constantine is performed
at the 60 degree point on the circle
containment specialists are presented
with masks joy sadness
anger apathy fear and foolishness
and must act out a farcical comedic play
before playing a dice game with one
another
procedure 420 per ronaldo is performed
at the circle's 120 degree point
this ritual involves a performance by a
band consisting of a flute
oboe clarinet french horn tympani
and bass drum it must be a live
performance
recordings have no effect procedure 430
epimetheus performed at the 180 degree
point
involves exchanging small gifts with
values not exceeding 4.28 cents usd
each gift exchange is followed by the
recitation of ceremony epimetheus a
and followed by scattering grain over
the chamber floor
procedure 440 casio performed at 240
degrees
involves the recitation of ceremony
casio a while participants bind their
feed with wool and drink 500 milliliters
of olive oil
they will then break apart a rock
weighing at least 200 kilograms with
hammers
ceremony casio b is recited throughout
while the previous procedures might
sound
weird it's after that point that the
containment rituals start to take a turn
for the gruesome
procedure 450 cairo is performed at the
300 degree point
in this ritual a d-class personnel has a
symbol drawn on their stomach with a
platinum base paint
a ring surrounding a dot with an arrow
pointed upwards at the 90 degree point
the d-class is then presented with a
blue cloak crown
and scepter before being restrained in
the chair and castrated with a hand
sickle as ceremony cairo a
is recited finally 460 umphalos is
performed at the zero degree point the
very top of the circle
this ritual the most gruesome of all
involves cooking
and eating a three-month-old infant
in case of containment breach site 100
is equipped with a nuclear warhead
just like all scp containment sites
which will be detonated if containment
ever
fails because of the complexity of the
procedures required to contain
scp-2845 some animosity started to
develop between the foundation personnel
stationed at site 100
and the outside contractors who had
conceived the containment rituals
they had to go through these
time-consuming elaborate
sometimes horrific procedures over and
over again
going around and around the circular
maze that made up the site
every 10 hours and there was no way of
being able to tell if the things they
were doing had
any effect on the creature and
containment at all on the 31st of
january 2012
site director dell finally approached
one of the containment consultants and
asked him why
exactly they had to uphold all this
pageantry
surely there had to be some other more
streamlined way of keeping the creature
in containment
the consultant denied this and explained
their reasoning
i find it sickening that after all the
struggle to contain this creature
pencil-pushing bureaucrats are still
seeking to cut corners where they cannot
be afforded to be cut
the ritual remain as it is and will not
be changed in any way
rituals do not work because of some
underlying laws such as those that
science operates on
rituals work because they are rituals
they work because an arbitrary set of
criteria has been met with exacting care
belief that meeting these arbitrary
criteria achieves a certain end assigns
power to the ritual
the actions that were once meaningless
now have been assigned meaning through
their repetition
and application this is how one seals
away
a god and this is a god
i know that the foundation does not
approve of using the term but it is
still the case the stag is a god
and it is not a petty local god it is
not one of the mild gods of earth or
some weaker spirit
that is bound by the strength of man's
belief we have for the time being
fooled it into thinking that we have
overpowered it
it does not understand that we do so
falsely it
is a god for god's words have power
ritual and belief hold greater power
over a god than all the laws of science
so why are the containment procedures
for scp-2845 so dramatic and complex
the answer is simple because the team
believes the rituals work
as a cosmic deity scp-2845 doesn't
follow any scientific laws as we
understand them
on earth but what it does understand is
the power of rituals and belief
the only reason it hasn't escaped is
that it responds to the beliefs of the
foundation personnel
and in turn it believes that it's being
held in containment
the consultant goes on he will not think
to escape or even to change its strategy
the idea will not even pass through its
mind he cannot comprehend the concept
it does not think in the way we think
truth be told i would not say
things at all this is an old god
it does not dabble in decisions
decisions are for creatures who may act
erratically
variably or out of line a god of this
strength
simply is it is an absolute
it acts as a force in building this
ritual we have shifted its being the
slightest bit
and now it is locked into a pattern of
behavior
it struggles against us we struggle
against it
and we are locked together an eternal
dance so long as the ritual remains
intact one last question remains though
when it comes to scp-2845 the rituals
that are performed to keep it in place
are far from random they seem so
specific that it feels impossible that
the outside consultants could have come
up with them out of the blue
what was their inspiration well in his
statement to site director
dell he mentions listening to the songs
of the converted
remember how the instances of scp-2845-1
were shown to not only be alive but
communicating with each other
telepathically
they were able to communicate with the
contractors as well
giving them the tools they needed to
create the prison that would hold their
god
if you're wondering how the converted
feel about having being transformed into
a mobile green monoliths
the consultant had an answer for that
question too they're not
suffering but they are no longer human
they are changed
utterly and so the rituals continue in
order to keep scp-2845 contained
perhaps one day a new technology will be
found or
simpler procedures will be given but
until that day
we're all lucky that there are others
who will subject themselves to horror
day after day
hour after hour for our behalf
now go check out scp-4205
in the eyes of the beholder and scp-2317
the devourer of worlds
adore to another world for more from the
foundation's files